[Music]
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are officially engaged and now the
couple's nearest and dearest are
weighing in the blink 182 drummer popped
the question on the beach in montecito
california and court shared this snap of
the romantic moment on instagram
alongside the caption quote forever
naturally the post received a ton of
love in the comments addison ray who
shared a pic of the proposal on her own
instagram story wrote quote i'm
screaming in all caps life has changed
so much but that should come as no
surprise since the tick tock star
previously told et she totally ships
kravis i'm obsessed
i'm obsessed i love courtney and i love
travis they're amazing people and i wish
them the best they're so cute winnie
harlow sent her congrats to the happy
couple too along with a heart eye emoji
kris jenner posted several snaps of the
love birds to instagram writing quote
congratulations to the most beautiful
adorable affectionate fabulous made for
each other couple in the world love you
guys court's sister khloe kardashian
swooped into the comments of court's
post with some heart emojis and kim
kardashian shared two comments one
featuring heart emojis and another
featuring engagement ring emojis i love
their relationship like they've
grown so much together and have really
like made some amazing um
just i mean to think that they've been
neighbors and friends for almost 15
years my neighbors for like a decade of
course the kkw beauty founder made her
feelings on courtney and travis's love
known during a stop by the ellen
degeneres show last month and all of a
sudden yeah they cannot keep their hands
off of each other i mean like
like they it's
crazy what is wrong with them they are
they are like at each other like it's
the last time they're going to see each
other all the time it's so cute you know
what that's what they do you know and
it's so cute and i love love so i love
them and when it comes to their
engagement kim is here for it she
tweeted this clip of the love birds
kissing at their engagement dinner
alongside the caption quote kravis
forever
yeah thanks to kim we got our first look
at the engagement bling this is such a
dream come true and while we still don't
know all the deets on that massive
diamond sparkler one expert tells e.t
they estimate the ring is between 8 and
10 carats and valued at over 500 000
i mean it was beautiful amazing
travis's two children 17 year old landon
and 15 year old alabama whom he shares
with his ex-wife shayna mookler also
shared moments from the engagement
celebration
landon captured this clip of the couple
kissing writing quote i'm so happy for
you guys love you guys so much he also
posted this clip to tick tock writing so
happy for me and my new family
meanwhile alabama shared this snap of
her dad giving court a sweet peck on the
cheek writing so happy for you guys and
while his ex hasn't directly weighed in
she seemingly alluded to the news on her
insta story with this message
temporarily closed for spiritual
maintenance when eti spoke to shaina in
march she opened up about travis's then
new relationship travis and i haven't
been together for almost a decade and
um you know we co-parent together we're
friends however um you know i don't know
anything about his personal life like
that we're not
um as close like that anymore you know i
mean it's been 10 years he has his own
world going on i kind of have my own
world um do i want him to be happy
absolutely i want him to
um i want him to be happy and you know
she makes him happy i think that's
awesome but back to that engagement a
source tells e.t the pair couldn't be
happier quote courtney and travis are
over the moon getting engaged was always
their natural next step and they are so
thrilled the proposal was gorgeous and
romantic and everything courtney wanted
[Music]
you